alors après philippe sollers et jean
hivernale est aussi c'est le
positionnement enfin bon tu meurs c'est
pas idiot parce que c'est un mix les
chants résonnent nous prépare un livre
s'appelle carré impudique lui raconte
ses histoires d'amour et c'est pas idiot
parce que comme c'est les femmes qui
achètent les livres c'est pas idiot de
faire des livres sur les femmes et
finalement qui sont à la gloire des
femmes d'amour way to sont mes coups de
coeur
toutes les femmes qui depuis que j'ai
cinq sites en m'ont ému et comme là
dedans on retrouve et jeanne d'arc et
antigone et lucie de châteaubriant et
plein d'autres et cordélia et opinions
ça peut pas aller plus loin tu dis qu'à
misrata que les femmes c'est un peu
comme une drogue pour toi c'est sa
raison de vivre c'est vrai est accrochée
aux femmes pourront peut être accroché
labrador les environnements féminin la
guerre j'ai travaillé dans une émission
qui s'appelait à la folie pas du tout
pour un joueur du style de musique c'est
pas la truie qui sera bien qu'avec deux
femmes qu'avec des femmes
il ya des collaboratrices pour un impôt
collaborateurs moi j'aime vraiment dans
l'environnement criminal parce que ça
apporte évidemment une douceur ça
apporte une certaine perversité
et qui me plaît beaucoup aux killers
avons surtout beaucoup d'ombré de
lumière en même temps ryan est un art du
maquillage du mensonge transformé en art
ça c'est le mensonge connectés oui ça me
fascine toujours étonné avec toi si le
ton tu pouvais pas repasser à parler des
filles et des femmes tu peux faire parce
que je pourrais faire un film ensemble
je me souviens d'un dimanche après midi
à la martinique où tu as passé
l'après-midi à parler avec une femme et
nous lequel a tous ensemble je me dis
mais qu'est ce qu'ils qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent se dire
c'est exactement comme quand on pénètre
dans un pays quand même comme on
découvre une géographie même une espèce
minérale ou animale chaoui complètement
et c'est toujours renouvelée c'est une
femme ne ressemble jamais à une autre
dans cet hymne est un cliché de que de
le dire mais c'est moi je défends grosse
avec des yeux mais à la fois olymique et
met à rire tu t'adaptes en huile elle
pas moins en moins d'une chance mais
j'ai déjà parlé à une femme qu'à un
homme sauf télévision alors bon il ya la
famille à les rencontres et pianiste a
enfin les stars où les héroïnes de la
littérature où les stars qui sont
parfois des rencontres aussi
oui c'est vrai c'est une canette génie
non non il est belge et liste un
portrait ouais ya une phrase sur adjani
comme ça tu dis l'autre nuit je ne t'ai
pas vu partir ça veut dire quoi ça
c'est à dire que l'hôte nuit j'ai pas dû
la voir partir ouais
nous vivrons
des livres avec décodeur sens avec ce
n'est pas à nîmes avec les codeurs j'ai
dit tu sais bien que tout paris va
passer un passé que j'ai essayé de
savoir y fera du délit
sa juliette b ouais inès de l'aef tu
sais bien que tout paris va passer son
temps à camille 2
c'est tout c'est bien tout paris passait
son temps aussi de se demander
ce qui s'est vraiment passé ou pas si
c'est comme ça je le sais mais je ne
connais pas la musique
vraiment je suis rien dans ses murs on
pourra comme l'avoine téléthon s'est
jamais si les ai rencontrés ou pas sauf
que je les aimais vraiment il ya une
femme qui a pas qui est sûrement été une
panne de ta vie n'était pas dans le
bouquin magazine barma non c'est pas ni
marie france brière me catherine barba
ni dominique cantien si christine 30
mais je parle aux docks une femme avec
lesquels j'ai travaillé un an aucune et
je marque en fait je travaillais assez
facilement et d'érable
mais qu'aucun n'a pas été le pérou quand
même si notre est bien entendu parler
dans les journaux tu disais qu'elle
devrait pas dire jamais rien dit pour
trouver moi je pouvais sortez moi un
seul extrait d'un à propos désagréables
à son égard même chose pour elle non se
respectent beaucoup des ronds se voit
très souvent non ça toujours bien été
j'ai trouvé qu'il ya des gens qui
adorent exactement plus c'est vrai que
on sait bien où on n'est pas dupe lui
dans la coulisse un certain nombre de
gens sont arrangés pour souffler sur des
certaines braise et jaune pour des
raisons extra professionnelles
qualifions les même carrément de
politique ça devenait arrangé c'est une
des personnes
de télévision je respecte le plus tous
ne sont pas et toutes ne sont pas
respectables
c'est vrai qu'il va faire une émission
sur les livres à la rentrée je réfléchis
à des solutions est en marche et c'est
bien pour moi et que et que robles pas
mal de cartes blanches
pas possible que je fasse autre chose si
je fais pas si je renouvelle pas mon
émission mais je m'aperçois que je
retombe souvent sur les mêmes invités
ça c'est un vrai dilemme d'être la
mission deux ans des jo gook je me
je souhaite toujours évité les gens qui
sont en promotion ce qu'on appelle par
un petit peu pour la remorque avant de
sortir son lit au machin qu'est moi
j'étais agacé avant oui ça c'était bien
trois mois et à trois mois
donc à partir de ce moment là c'est
assez difficile de retrouver un peu
d'authenticité des gens qui trouvent pas
là pour toi tu crois que c'est possible
de concurrencer pivot ah non moi je
marche
d'autres
galopade là j'ai fait autre chose dans
la tête et ne ressemble en rien à son
émission entendu une fois qui n'est pas
ton visage à l'écran qui trouve un peu
d'art auront
un taux répugne au nom bizarre non
oui mais j'ai dû je n'aime pas l'idée du
visage repasser mais le mien comme le
tien je n'aime pas l'idée d'être dans
une petite boîte de ressembler nikon
électroménagère d'avoir d'être sur 58 62
d'avoir des gestes relativement
policiers d'avoir une cravate ou même
une chemise lacoste pour ça devient
presque un symbole
ouais j'aime pas l'idée de d'être
assimilée à une étiquette anti ardisson
c'est le propos un poids c'est le soft
machin truc ça j'aime j'aime pas on est
en est si peu ça on est un petit bout de
ça on a un petit poêle détails vers
l'iss à la téléconférence ou réduit
beaucoup oui parce que là on raconte
froid contre sa vraie vie on raconte ses
fantasmes ses envies
son envie de sortir de sa grande peur de
vieillir
non non pas encore mais je n'aime pas du
tout et ça j'en parle dans mon livre
c'est l'idée de
il est de la compromission à venir
j'ai pensé assez stupidement et
peut-être aussi stupide l'ancrage à
l'âge de 15 ans je pensais que c'était à
40 ans ont commencé justement à tomber
aller de l'autre côté de la parenté
avoir des petits poils de moisissures de
quelque chose quand on accepte il fait
des choses qui vous plaisent pas comme
ça j'ai l'impression de relativement
bien tenir ma vie pour l'instant mais je
me méfie quand même
mais d'après peur d'être chaud par
exemple
à kerdurand je ne foutais je n'aime pas
ma tête que sont le premier exige pas
avec les filles de la bande et où était
comme ça j'ai horreur de genre de
questions encore plus des gens ne
répondent donc vois pas ce que ça te
ressemble si peu moi qui te connais mais
ça je sais que c'est uniquement une
question pour pour faire plaisir et pour
justifier une réputation cd cd des
chansons j'ai connaissance mais à
bordeaux
oui on n'est pas obligé d'y répondre
d'une part et puis c'est des sujets qui
n'est jamais abordée qui m'intéresse
absolument pas non liste la conversation
avec les parents
c'est beaucoup de monde excusez moi
c'est non
dernière question est-ce que tu
t'appelles patrick poivre patrick poivre
d'arvor
je m'appelle tactique du poids parce que
je suis né comme ça
et depuis quelques temps une banane avec
notamment parce que mon grand père 2 en
argent et avec mon frère olivier c'est
quelqu'un
m'admirer infiniment c'était le premier
à rome de la famille à écrire un
puisque hull j'en existe oui raconte
d'auteur aux éditions sud est remis à
rodez et poèmes de droit et alors je
pense qu'on trimballe sa avec luna de
souvenirs c'était quelque chose
d'exceptionnel depuis l'es3 puis les
deux petits-fils et la petite fille on a
écrit 14
mais pour nous ça reste une génération
c'est vrai mais moi je l'admets
rapidement cet homme là s'il est parti
de rien et orphelins à 4 ans il monte à
la ville entre guillemets à l'âge de 12
ans j'adore cet homme j'étais il ya huit
jours j'étais arrivé au sa mère est mort
à rio elle avait deux ans et c'est
nourrir une famille et j'étais super et
demi j'étais ému j'ai pensé que qu'à lui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu